[Music]
hello and welcome to chinese whispers
with me cindy yoo every episode i'll be
talking to journalists experts and
long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more there will be a smattering of
history to catch you up on the
background knowledge and some context
how do the chinese see these issues
this year always on the chinese
communist party's leadership as we're
coming up to another national party
congress it's where president xi is
meant to be cementing his third term in
power
but how much do we really know about
this generation of communist leaders the
ones who might replace presidency in the
future
in this episode in particular i want to
talk about their formative experiences
what were the things that impacted them
and made them who they are as they were
growing up on this episode i'll be
joined by professor kerry brown who's at
king's college london and author of a
recent book on president xi calls xi a
study in power so he's an expert on the
man
and also by professor steve tang who is
a historian at soas
so steve i want to start with you can we
look at the politburo standing committee
it's average age of 67 which means that
they would have all been teenagers when
the cultural revolution started so i
want to start with that experience which
must be in one of the most formative
moments in their lives
for listeners who don't know what was
the experience like for young people
during the cultural revolution perhaps
you could start with the early years
with the red guards
well the cultural revolution was an
amazing time for the young people in
china
never
did young people in china experienced
anything like the cultural revolution
before
or since then
they were being unleashed
by order of the great chairman mao
to break things
to
struggle against
old folkies who were revolutionaries
even if they were extremely senior
people
they were given a license to rebel
and some of them a lot of them were then
sent down to the countryside to learn
from the peasants
and in all that experience
they
were able to attempt and try things that
your average teenager anywhere in the
world would never have an experience to
and they will also have acquired some
kind of
sense of the reality of power
they know
or at least they learned that they must
say the politically correct thing
and then they must
first and foremost
protect number one
because nobody else is going to
i think
different individuals draw different
lessons from the cultural revolution
you will have some who became senior
leaders today
who will think that
never again the cultural revolutions or
anything like that
you also have some i feel
at least
xi jinping who thinks that the cultural
revolution was a wonderful thing
and the red guards then said they were
these school children essentially who
were enlisted by the chairman in order
to create a revolution and what they did
was often against the traditional
confusion authority or authorities of
you know teacher to students because
they would denounce their teachers they
would denounce their parents
kerry is it fair to say that what where
you know this generation of party
leaders do you think they would have
been red guys themselves
no i mean i actually looked at the 25
members of the current full pollock
bureau
and
uh a number of them were born in 1950 to
um i think the youngest is 1963 that's
so that's quite a kind of big period the
older ones would certainly be sent down
news
and some of them would have been later
kind of you know campaigns uh the sent
down youth campaign was really launched
in 68 and i think xi jinping was
actually sent
to sanji um province in 60 early very
early 1969
and so their their experiences of the
culture evolution are quite diverse i
mean the very young ones would have a
memory of it like you'd have a memory of
like being an infant school
and then the older ones would have a
memory of being you know kind of in
campaigns and things and maybe involved
with red guard groups so i couldn't find
any explicit mention of that
uh if you think of a failed leader like
poor boy
i mean there were these these rumors
that he'd been extremely activist red
guard and denounced his father an
elitist leader for boyibor
when he was at ching hai university in
the 1960s
and in fact um i believe that um
xi jinping was
um i mean he was at ching hai university
later now i mean
xi jinping's predecessor
uh was also a qinghua around about that
time
uh but there's no association with him
and redguard so i think it's very
variable i mean the culture evolution
was a very complicated movement and
people's experience of it i think was
very very variable which this group of
people kind of testified to their very
different experiences and what they did
steve it's partly that because
somewhere like beijing for example would
have had more of the epicenter of the
revolution of the movement and if you
were growing up elsewhere in china
perhaps you weren't affected so much and
it just gives us flavor because i think
in the west it's often easy to think of
the red guards as what epitomizes the
cultural revolution but how prevalent
was that movement to join for your
average young person during that time
it was in fact uh countrywide
you might have greater intensities in
places like beijing or shanghai or
tangent or guangzhou
but even in other places the cultural
revolution mostly reached
a bit less in the minority
heavy border regions of china but
generally
young people were able to travel across
the country
the railway system was being required to
provide free travel for
young people who went around to
see the country and learned about the
revolution a cultural revolution
interrailing
rail car it was a kind of free
interrailing for cultural
revolutionaries
but then that was the intention of major
jung that he was going to use the
cultural revolution in part
to raise a new generation of
revolutionaries who are beholden to him
but not to the party
and that's why you can have other very
senior leaders of the communist party
who could be the subject of
struggles and
beatings and public humiliation
and yet
everybody uh
everybody were supposed to be pupils of
the great chairman
and people took advantage of that and
make that travel and do a lot of things
that they would not otherwise have been
able to do without the freedom of the
cultural revolution
and you already mentioned being the sent
down youths can you tell us about that
because by a few years into the cultural
revolution that kind of red guard
further was getting a bit too much and
mao actually had a different policy for
young people
well for the sendang you
a large part of the intention was to
send the
educated somewhat educated urban you
young people into the countryside to
have a taste of what life is like in the
countryside and so they are supposed to
learn from the peasants
but when they get to the countryside
they probably weren't that much they
really want to learn in terms of
intellectual learning learning in
in the sense of what we think of as
schools
the learning was about the hard
reality of how harsh
life could be
in the countryside in china
and how
back breaking labor
were required of the peasants
and how
in spite of the youth
they were
totally unprepared
for the intensity of hard labor that was
normal routine daily requirements of
life in the countryside
how incredibly incompetent they were
compared to the illiterate
dirty
unhygienic
peasants who were able to produce crops
that they couldn't
who were able to carry heavy loads that
they couldn't
but yet
you will have some of those
really smart ones who will find niched
in the countryside
and be able to develop their leadership
skills
and in some cases win over the local
peasant communities and make something
for themselves i think xi jinping is one
of those people who managed to do that
and that perhaps affect how he remembers
um his sentence experience
well kerry let's talk about sustained
pain's sent down experience because in
your book you quote him
a saying of that time later on
he says later in life whenever i ran
into difficulties i would think of that
period how could i not carry on now when
i could work under those extremely
difficult conditions
so it building him this determination at
least he wants us to think that
yeah i mean the politicization of
society from
1966 when the cultural revolution
started
uh you know as part of a kind of well a
political movement cultural movement
you know kind it was a very
complicated phenomena
i mean the one thing it did do is i
think for the first time really in
modern chinese history there was a
shared belief system even though
uh people struggled with how to define
that uh you know kind of mao
was a
mao zedong thought uh you know was
something you had to
embrace and have in your most intimate
life in in many ways and i suppose
secondly their kind of practices the
things that people did every day
were kind of mandated by the movement
you know the schools and colleges closed
and so
uh someone like xi jinping basically
extended ended their formal education
around about 67-68 i mean he was an
elite school next to zhong hai in
beijing
and then was quite a young
kind of member of this initial tranche
of south down news
so i mean a lot of accounts of this in
chinese are
dubious because they're issued today and
they kind of reinforce this idea of xi
jinping the man who has eaten bitterness
you know he's sure cool i think the
chinese phrase is you know he's really
you know kind of
earned the right to have the position
he's got today i think lee kuan yew the
late leader singapore called him you
know asia's nelson mandela because of
the way he'd suffered at this time
but i mean it did give a very
distinctive world view to people and i
think in looking at the accounts at
least i use in this book on she i do
sort of appreciate that it's it's
definitely a distinctive generational
culture that the people who remember
this uh before 1976 when it broadly
ended and the people afterwards who
don't remember are very different in
their world view
and one of the things about the accounts
of his colleagues or contemporaries at
that time is you know the idea of you
know just getting off a train and then
being taken to various parts of this
locality around here now i mean it's
quite a big area
and being sort of put on these kangs
these brick kind of things you know beds
and
the thing that kind of is most striking
is their complaints about being bitten
all night by mosquitoes and then having
as you know beijing as to get used to
this very different diet
again that's kind of quite a radical
change especially as your parents you
know aren't around and for xi jinping
his father had been abstinent since 1961
because of political issues in beijing
so this is a pretty unstable environment
to have your adolescent years when
already you're going through a lot of
different changes in your life so i
think that's instability is sort of
impacted on the psychology of this
generation and made them maybe respond
in the ways they do to both domestic
issues in the outside world
just on his father xi jong xing is one
of those early communist revolutionaries
you know he was with mao when mao was
exit
he was with melbourne and i was exiled
to yang and you know he was vice premier
of china before his downfall but then he
did have a downfall and that was before
the cultural revolution so shi xi
jinping is what we can call a grangadei
a princeling you know as close to
communist uh royalty as you can get
what was what would that upbringing have
done to him because not everyone who is
a leader in china now grew up in that
kind of elite outcome but also then that
the great disgrace that came kerry what
do you think
we are all very interested in the family
backgrounds of elite of current
political elite figures and by political
elite figures i mean people who are in
the central committee and i think it is
important i mean family is important in
a chinese society generally and it
orientates people where there are so
many other networks it's it's a really
strong i think bond
but there's quite a few people you know
i mentioned boris eli earlier
and you know i mean his elite background
was far more stellar i mean boy boy was
probably a more significant leader than
xi jongsoon although c junction was a
very significant leader
i mean the
impact of having your
first part of your childhood so from
1953 to broadly 1961 you know kind of
fairly secure with your father being an
important member of the propaganda kind
of organization you know kind of vice
premier dealing with culture i mean
important position and then completely
removed this must be a sort of you know
very disorientating because really after
that i can only find you know a couple
of records of xi jinping having contact
with his father i believe there probably
was more contact couldn't be nothing and
i mean he's his mother who's still alive
uh cheating is obviously you know she
continued to kind of be the matriarch
for the family and i suppose that counts
for the very strong bond he has with his
mother to this day the other thing is um
there's kind of story of one of his
sisters or his half-sister because she's
been married before you know he married
xi jinping's mother
uh kind of committing suicide in the
culture evolution and this is all very
impactful and disruptive stuff
so i think for each individual it had a
very different impact uh all you can say
is that it was a period when people i
think will did feel insecure and the
party in a way
is sort of this kind of almost this
patriarchal entity that people
feel they were protected by
i think the psychology of people's
relationships with mao in some ways is
strange because that he spared people
and was therefore in their minds
merciful to them and as i said in this
book that xi jinping is a born-again
communist he was spared he is grateful
to the man who left him alone
steve is that how you read the paradox
because i do think there is a paradox in
in that he has such a disruptive
childhood no no which to which no little
amount of that is because of chinese
communist party yet kerry says in his
book you know she treats the party as a
faith you know how is it that he came
out of that period becoming more further
into communist
i think something else that we need to
bear in mind is that
for what you described as the
core of the red second generations
the real princelings the offsprings of
senior
first generation communist party leaders
they have a sense that they are the real
second generation of the communist party
they don't quite necessarily look at it
in the way that we have been looking at
political generations in china so that
xi jinping is now the fifth generation
leader
there's much more of a sense that they
are the people they are the generation
who should be inheriting
from mao
and xi jinping fundamentally takes a
view that
he
is
picking up from mao in between it was an
interangum with your dong xiaoping zhang
ji min and hu jintao
i don't see xi jinping paying that much
respect to don chappen if anything he
likes to play that down he would be seen
that he having inherited it he is the
person who is going to make china
great again in a way that even chairman
mao had not managed to do that
and kerry as steve has already said you
know there was incredible freedom to the
time because
schools and universities were closed for
essentially years for some pretty
formative years of these of these
children's lives
what impact did that have because
essentially if you're not going to
school i mean i i said there is a
wonderful film called in the heat of the
sun yang guantanamo which is all about
the kids growing up in beijing during
that time and you know chasing girls
trying out smoking mocking mocking
street battles all that kind of stuff
instead of you know incredibly
politicized or educational things so
essentially a lot of people didn't get a
formal education
yeah i mean from 68 till around about 73
74
i mean schools weren't really
functioning xi jinping went to
qinghua to do i think um engineering
um
from
70 i think for 74 75 as part of this
scheme there's some controversy over
this because it was really a kind of
sort of you know it's an elite
university but it sort of always been
rumored that this was a bit easier for
someone like him because they had
connections and things even at that time
that was definitely thrown on
i mean it's kind of interesting if you
think
him and his sense of
in you know entitlement people often
refer to this i think there's a
wikileaks where the american embassy
interviewed someone who'd been linked
with him at this time and they said you
know he had a strong sense that these
were the custodians of the party their
family you know meant that they had the
right to be where they are and people
that
know and have met xi jinping you know
sort of foreign leaders have commented a
lot i noticed on his confidence and this
sort of sense that you know he kind of
feels like this is his entitlement to be
where he is
but the weird thing is if you look at
the people who are talked to others
being potential one day
uh successors they're not many of them
and it's not hard to kind of it's not
easy to sort of pin these down i just
look at their ages something like
huchenhua or changmingara are
not so much dingsuishiang but
dingshushyang has been very closely
associated with him
these people
definitely don't have elitist
backgrounds i mean they're from quite
humble backgrounds uh wang yang who's
often also i mean he's a bit older but
talked as a you know very capable leader
and he's in the standing committee now
humble background
um
so if you look at the people around him
there's not many um who have the same
kind of stellar royal background and i
wonder what that says about his real
attitude to these elites i mean it seems
like it's okay for him to you know kind
of be with his sense of entitlement but
uh not that people around him should
have it um and maybe
you know this issue with the great
battle between him and boyce eli was
probably about this issue of you know
within the elites there are big big kind
of differences and that you can't have
two tigers on the mountain basically you
know you just can't have it uh and so i
think that this probably explains why
the people around him don't share this
sort of elitist background or not not
not anything in the same sort of league
as he does
steve when we talk about eliteness then
do we also mean out of touch because
when we're talking about being the sent
down used i mean that kind of on the
ground experience is something that a
lot of politicians in the west or the
east
do not have at all you know boris
johnson has never worked a farm field in
his life
do you think that has
translated into people feeling you know
really as kerry says eating bitterness
really understanding what it is that
poor people in the country live through
does that translate into their policy
making later on
i think it's a very logical point to
make that it
is something that we would expect it to
be the case
and i am
in fact somewhat skeptical that it might
that it may actually be the case
but the reality is that it was a very
very very long time ago when xi jinping
had the experience of the bitterness of
the countryside
he is now remembering it those
experience with
rosy glasses
he is
as i think kerry once described him as
chairman of everything
he is surrounded by
increasingly small group of trusted
advisors
and he doesn't really now have much of a
sense of what real life in
chinese cities towns villages or
countryside is like
he hasn't been back to the
uh every man restaurant for his
uh
dumplings
since he first tried
within a year or two of him becoming
leader now all these are gone so
his capacities to relate to
the kind of problems that
uh everyday chinese persons living in
the
20
20s
will have to face
i think it just isn't there
i don't think he can be more in touch
with everyday life
in beijing let alone china as a whole
then boris johnson east
with that in this country outside of
perhaps
i think steve yeah i think steve steve
makes a a good point really in fact
you if he if xi jinping wanted to just
go to a normal place he couldn't do it i
mean i don't think
when i i think rowan kalik a journalist
nostra um british australian journalist
said in a book about the party a few
years ago
when you go through that door and become
a significant provincial or national
leader
you will never stay in a hotel where
other people are staying you know next
to you
you'll always be in very privileged
places you will never get on public
transport you will never get a plane
which other people from the public are
getting on in fact you'll have a wall
around you
and i think that's much more i mean you
could say it's true in american and
other politics maybe but
there's no way you can get through that
barrier if you're a member if you're
allowed by singing a member of the
public and in fact i think when wenjaba
was primary premier you know in hu
jintao's period one person a petitioner
did get through and presented him with a
petition and this was a massive problem
because then he was obliged to do
something so it's absolutely crucial
that they are kept apart from the public
and the public are kept apart from them
it's really really uh i think quite
extreme it's fascinating because i think
in chinese um the chinese mindset as far
as we can say there is a chinese mindset
there is this idea of the emperor going
in amongst the people you know this is
way for suffering you know kind of
secretly hiding who you are to see how
normal people are living how local
officials are being corrupt or whatever
it is and i think it's interesting
because clearly that's still important
because in the law of these leaders they
have to go out for these photo ops to
eat the dumplings um to also you know
say how much they were in touch with the
people during the year yeah and years um
to carry a point that you make in your
book that you know this is part of the
story about xi jinping that he is in
touch i wonder if carrie what do you
think why is that it's still important
for them to put forward that perspective
even though there is probably not true
well so the story always was that uh
because of social media they don't
physically go amongst the people but
i've never been told by a chinese
journalist a few years ago that every
day they get on their computers in
jongdanghai and they go onto social
media and that's how they see
you know what's happening in the public
now of course interestingly with
lockdowns in shanghai and all this kind
of anger that's building up in china and
incredible you know control of what goes
on social media it seems like they can't
even get an insight into what the public
think there too i mean i did come across
one of the um i think it's tai chi um
the current uh mayor of uh by secretary
of beijing um sort of runs his own weibo
account or did run his own weight or
account and you know apparently this has
got 10 million followers and you know he
kind of goes and sort of asks people's
opinions but i i sort of can't imagine
uh you would be able particularly with
the registrations that you have to do
now in china uh you know kind of just
rock into a conversation with a you know
politburo leader and say i think you're
doing a terrible job i mean it's not
going to happen
so it's this is a very big enigma
what
information they actually get about what
is happening
and it's probably got worse because the
controls are so much stricter now and
the paradox is that probably the very
very few people that tell them anything
that might be vaguely real
are or used to be foreign leaders who
kind of at least could say you know
there's this problem and that problem
it's really tough to think of how
officials or on social media and other
people in particular in xi jinping's era
are able to be that candid because the
costs if you uh are candid are really
high now really really
high yeah and that's something that i
look at in a recent article of mine
talking about shanghai's lockdown and
social media censorship where i found
that actually there are millions of
analysts employed by both um the
government and the private sector who
just literally tore through social media
to get the next trends as well um on
that point about being in touch with uh
the public kerry the ccp also draws a
lot of its top talent from regions by
which i mean party secretaries
are sent to different provinces they're
people who cut their teeth on frontier
lands xingping himself spent years
outside of the capital how does that
work is it something that the party sees
merit in to have that regional knowledge
well certainly been the norm for the
last 30 years i i mean zhang zaming had
come from
shanghai and then he'd previously been
in uh chang i think it was jiling
province
and shandong province
famously had been in a lot of western
provinces and then in tibet uh you know
and xi jinping had spent 15 16 years in
fujian five years in turtian and then i
think seven or eight months in shanghai
i mean i think the assumption is
you've got to kind of learn how to be a
ruler and in provinces some of them are
massive
uh i mean
province is nearly a hundred more more
than 100 million people such one
province is about the same
the second is that they can kind of
basically see what your ability is in
building networks in places where you're
often an outsider i mean this is from
imperial times you send the key leader
from outside although that's for some of
these leads is no longer the case
and i suppose
the final thing is that there are that
many big big jobs in beijing i mean
ministerial positions are not really
kind of the key ones in many ways the
provincial party secretaries of whom i
think about five on the you know pollock
bureau are really powerful people
so i think that is the structural
justification
and you know it kind of has meant that
the last three core leaders
uh have been from strong provincial
backgrounds and that's given them the
kind of track record that men that they
could then be trusted to sort of have
the final crown jewel
of being the central leader
steve one other way that people are out
of touch or potentially out of touch in
this generation is that a lot of them
have just been politicos since the 19 i
don't know 70s because that's normally
when they join the party when they start
going up the party ladder for xi jinping
as well as for other people and maybe
the one
one of the few exceptions to this is one
corning who is often dubbed the brain of
of whatever president is in power at the
time because he was actually an academic
until the 1990s at which point he
started climbing the ladder so what does
that do to your mindset because in
between 1970 and now china has gone
through an incredible change not least
driven by the private sector and none of
these people have any experience of that
well one cooling is a very interesting
person to
take into account here
he was quite a
uh
recognized
professor before he was picked by zhang
ji means to go to beijing
and fudan was very his colleagues at
fudani were proud that it had happened
but after
wang huling moved to beijing
he cut off his links with his former
colleagues
basically he
decided that he really would like to be
a party man
rather than stay on as an academic or as
a kind of interface
between academia
and the party apparatus
now he clearly was right
in his own way and in terms of his
career progression
he's gone further than any professor had
ever gone
uh in the in the chinese
system in terms of the rich of power
but he
i think does not
understand
what has happened in chinese academia
since he left full damned for jung nang
hai
and he doesn't want to know
kerry can i get your thought on that
question as well in terms of
how much do you know what's going on in
e-commerce companies or how much do you
know what's going on in the stock
exchange that kind of stuff you know
it's in i think oh
we talk in the uk about career
politicians right and these are the
epitome of those
well i mean you can know and i probably
i've been to alibaba's headquarters in
hangzhou and you know it's the great
gold box of information on what chinese
people are selling and buying and i mean
this is what everyone wants to get hold
of and you can know a lot but what do
you understand
i mean how is this interpreted
i mean the interesting thing about this
leadership i mean there are two things
one is if you wanted a realization of
plato's dream in the republic of
philosophers becoming kings you kind of
got it i mean these are a bunch of
philosophers right they talk like you
know philosophical uh kind of uh you
know people rather than administrators
that's the first thing and the second
thing is i think it's all about you know
this core issue of identity and identity
politics and how it's not the sort of
enlightenment project of you know
rationalizing quantifying being
positivist it's really about what you
feel
and therefore you know you can have
endless information but how do you kind
of feel about that and what do you kind
of you know this idea of chinese
identity being so uniform and strongly
asserted i think that's at the core of
the fight in hong kong you know you've
got to have this sense of chinese
identity be proud of it and don't be
disloyal to it
in xinjiang i mean i read an excellent
study by michael clark and others of the
issue there again no compromise yeah
might be ethnic minorities you might be
muslims you might be whatever you've got
to embrace chinese identity with a
capital c and a capital i and it goes
back beyond communism to confucianism
it's deep and you know i think this is
really the sort of
core element of of this leadership that
it's sort of
not a rational project it's definitely
the same kind of identity politics that
we see in america in europe and
therefore it is intrinsically um un uh
you know unpredictably where it might
end up but it will continue to assert
the importance of identity and one
calling has been the great architect of
that not just in the last 10 years but
in the last 25 or 30. and they're all
men they're all han well they're not all
men because central and is around you
know she's broken the glass ceiling um
but mostly mostly men and all han uh and
yeah coming from quite similar um
similar in some ways backgrounds and
steve can i ask you a question about um
institution like being institutionalized
because what inspired me to do this
episode was my conversation with um the
academic wong fung from the university
of california and irvine um and he was
talking about how in the 90s the
communist leaders themselves drank their
own kool-aid drank the kool-aid of the
previous generations the propaganda
about the one child policy and that's
why it took so long for them to uten
presumably that's what happens when you
grow up in one party apparatus for
almost half a century
oh they definitely believe in their own
propaganda
i mean
we are now talking about a generation of
leaders
who grew up
after the communist party had gained
power
and after the communist party has said
historical narrative
something that xi jinping has now come
up with a new
concept called historical nihilism which
means that anybody who tries to
challenge or contradict
the official party version of history
will have committed a crime
so it will be a criminal offence
to say to
members of the chinese communist party
that's the
communist party of china historically
was the strongest advocate
for taiwan's independence
and you could even go back to the
six-party congress
which was held in moscow in 1928
where you will find documentation
that proved that
going beyond just the records of foreign
journalists like edgar snow to whom
chairman mao famous famously said that
in
in the start of the silent japanese war
that
the policy of the communist party
ultimately is to support the people of
taiwan and korea to achieve their
independence
and this is a commitment the communist
party of china would make
now these are all you know
chinese government records
you cannot say that so your generation
of leaders from xi jinping himself down
don't actually know that
because nobody
can say it to them and please or even
present those historical documents to
him without
risking
having committed the heinous crime of
historical nihilism
so you have a situation where they do
believe in a lot of their own propaganda
and the same thing
somewhat similar
will be remembered by a lot of people in
terms of the uh
the great leap forward
sorry i need to correct myself the
people who actually live through the
great leap forward would remember the
reality even if they cannot say it
but for the generation of people who
grew up
as toddlers or
very very young children who were not
living in the parks of china that face
severe
starvation
they would just believe in the party's
version of the three difficult years
when harvest
got into difficulties because of
challenges in climate and
weather and conditions
and
all kinds of things which were not some
the responsibility of the party
when historical record will show that in
terms of the climate of those three
years
there was nothing untowards
crops failed
because of party policy not because of
weather conditions
they would not be they would not know
so they will believe in their own
version of history and
in your terms join their own kuwait
can i quickly briefly briefly pick you
up on one thing you said about taiwan
just to check was mao in support of
taiwan independence because of a kind of
marxist anti-imperialism idea that
people should be self-governing was that
why
well
it was the policy of the third communist
international the common turn
that
all oppressed people
colonial people should be supported to
achieve their independence
and because
japan was the colonial power of taiwan
for 50 years from
1895 until 1945
so it was simply something that was the
policy of the third communist
international that mile completely
embraced
you have here really in a sense raise
the other interesting
uh kool-aid that they regularly drink
the signification of
marxism leninism
in fact the communist party of china
existed as the china chapter of the
coming turn for most of its early years
pretty much nearly until well in fact
until the third communist international
was one up in the 1940s
and the party came to power
with massive
assistance both military and economic
from the ussr
it was not
the mystical
rifle plus
millet
that chairman mao used to defeat the
guamandang military the pla or the red
chinese red army use huge amount of
artillery very effectively at it from
the middle to the later stage of the
chinese civil wars to win power
yeah
kerry i want to bring you back to
welcoming and do a comparison with xi
jinping and i don't want to sound
elitist here but my question is is xi
jinping actually that smart by which i
mean
you're rolling your eyes at me but hear
me out hear me out one corning has you
know this amazing career as an academic
uh lee kurtian studied law at peking
university you've got other people who
have had very stellar careers at top
universities you mentioned there that xi
jinping was also at tinghua university
but you said you you kind of went over
this this you know rumors of um
having the guarantee having networks to
get him in because he was part of this
gong being
scheme in his work peasant soldier
scheme
a he's not a worker or peasant or
soldiers how did he get onto that and b
that scheme is inherently unmeritocratic
right because it was a more positive
discrimination kind of thing to get
different people from different class
backgrounds on so
do we know anything about how smart this
man is is he actually
that smart
i
i mean i i've met him once in 2007 when
he was briefly party secretary of
shanghai and i've sort of got a memory
of a very
typical you know sort of provincial or
high level leader
who kind of was well briefed and said
the right thing and was quite avuncular
um
as i say
since then of course he's become a
different kind of character at least in
terms of public image
um
i don't know i mean politicians do they
have to be smart i mean if only smart
people succeeded at politics we would
not end up with the leaders we've got in
britain or probably in america or
elsewhere
but they do have to be good politicians
and they have to be good politicians
within their system
and so self-evidently i think that xi
jinping is an effective politician in
his system now because of all of the
antagonisms towards you know the chinese
political system towards china
geopolitically and all the rest of it
to say that xi jinping is an effective
politician is sometimes quite
antagonizing uh for some but i mean he
is and he clearly is he has managed to
in ways that have surprised many and i
mean surprise is important for
politicians uh cleared away almost
everything around him i mean as i say at
the end of this book you know the stage
has sort of weirdly become clear
uh it's only him sitting there now uh
we're moving into a congress later this
year the 20th where it is most unlikely
that we're going to see a strong sign of
any successor and this is a big big
disruption and i i think that's very
unlikely um and you know this saw this
sort of very complicated story of 1.4
billion people with all of their
diversity with the incredible complexity
of the world now with the complexity of
its economy has become a story about
one figure
that is effective politics even if it's
not particularly pleasant politics so i
mean it might not be that he has a high
iq i mean i'm sure his iq is okay i'm
sure you know he's not an idiot but i
mean in terms of political iq if you can
kind of create a thing like that i think
he's very effective and finally i mean
politician what are politicians i mean i
think max faber said that they were
magicians or warlords
and i think we're in the age of
magicians politicians as magicians you
know
putin is a warlord but that hasn't ended
well right or it looks like it's not
going to be ending well
so xi jinping is a sort of magician and
creating these sorts of you know symbols
and images and the idea of the china
dream and these are all very vague the
belt and road
but they do fulfill a function because
they do the most key alchemy alchemy
which is to create simplicity from
complexity and i think that's the core
job of a chinese leader to create
simplicity from what is intrinsically
an incredibly complicated historical
social and political story and i think
that's what he does he's the simplifier
the dissim he doesn't like a big
ambiguity
and he doesn't uh obviously like
complexity although china is a complex
place so that's i think what he does
steve just to mention one calling again
not that i'm a massive fan or anything
but i think it's an interesting foil for
the question i'm about to ask which is
just about this generation's
international experience do they have
much are they cosmopolitan because when
we consider mazda don't
lack of international experience
compared to denjalping or joe and lies
international experience i feel that you
can see there's a difference in the
cosmopolitan outlooks and how they deal
with foreign leaders for example one
hunning i mentioned him because he spent
six months in america which it sounds
like a lot but more than really a lot of
what other uh chinese leaders have done
and certainly see as well so do you
think that matters does that come into
things
i think it certainly matters the fact
that uh some of the top-level chinese
leaders have now
spent some time in foreign countries i
mean you have one holy and in fact you
also had xi jinping who spent
a couple of months in iowa which was
also the place where i think ron
williams spent a few months when he was
doing his initial field work in the
united states
the issue here really is that what kind
of lessons they are drawing
from the experience of their foreign
travel study or living and working
situations
i think we have in the case of one
cooling the book that he published
after he
uh spent his six months in the united
states it has been sort of
noticed again as
america versus america
which
in some ways were very perceptive of
some of the negative
sides of american society
but it's also a very
um
one-sided view of american society the
united states is such a complex place
with so many different dimensions
you have one wounding seeing
one particular dimension
quite
uh perceptively
but not apparently acknowledging many of
the other dimensions of american society
and the united states as a country
nowhere for examples do we hear either
from huang or other chinese leaders
the key
other key lessons that one can easily
draw from the experience of the united
states
one could either refers to the pearl
harbor of december 1941
or
september 11th
attacks
and how the united states
when under attack
would respond
how the americans would come together
um
again that is only one dimension of
american society and i don't want to say
that this is what america is but we will
need to have that
nuances and the breadth and the depth of
understanding
really to be able to
have the confidence that the top-level
chinese leaders
will be able to contextualize
their policy towards the united states
in a way that is
appropriate and well
nuanced and effective in getting what
needs to be achieved
having a very one-sided view and
understanding partial understanding of
the united states potentially can be
even more dangerous
than not understanding it
because if you don't know
you will ask somebody who does
if you think you know
when you don't know very much
it's a much more dangerous place to be
in
this actually leads very nicely on to
the next question about the next
generation of political leaders in china
as far as we can say um
because
presumably people who are coming up now
will be you know experiencing reform and
opening they will be traveling much much
more in younger when they're younger
maybe even studying abroad does that
matter or will it matter kerry do you
think i mean obviously we don't know for
sure but i'd love to hear your thoughts
on that whether or not that kind of
western education that kind of um and
maybe covet as a breaking point in the
kind of course how cosmopolitan the
modern chinese have become but certainly
from you know 1990 to maybe 2020 there
were so many chinese who were going all
over the world all of the time do you
think the next generations could be more
cosmopolitan is that a good thing
well it depends what you mean by
cosmopolitan i mean i think we're living
in a period where there's a big backlash
against globalization and the idea that
being local is being good you don't like
citizens from nowhere so
i don't know
whether uh the big return e kind of
population of the last 30 years which is
millions now i think it's about sort of
two and a half no three three and a half
million
uh you know this is going to have a big
impact and domestic chinese politics
because people who have been educated
abroad
uh give very variable accounts of how
that education these days is valuable
back in china look i mean i think if we
look at where we were a decade ago
uh before just before xi jinping came to
power in you know 12 2012
we kind of had lots of clarity on you
know there will be a succession um
although it looked a bit rickety at some
point it was always pretty certain and
who the figures were you know they're
only a few figures but yeah they were
definitely figures um
now of course no real clues i mean i
mentioned earlier these figures
you know kind of and then li chang who
um actually uh kind of hong kong he's
got
one degree from hong kong uh university
business ironically um
you know the party secretary of shanghai
so maybe what's happening in shanghai at
the moment has made him a little less
likely to be pushed up
the point is there's not a huge number
of people in this potential kind of
elite top elite leadership pool i mean
you know it it's really really small
and you'd have thought that there would
be a little more clarity over
who is really well placed and if you
look at the current um 25 members of the
pollock politburo in theory
um
14 can continue because they'll be under
the age of or about 68 at the end of
this year so you know they can continue
if that if that is still kept but that
might not be kept and that includes lee
ka chang actually he was born in 1955
and in the standing committee of seven
you know maybe four can continue
um are these people able to occupy the
position that xi jinping has created
were he either to vacate it or move
aside
uh it's very hard because he's created
this persona and this all it it has been
created for him and by him and with him
uh this sort of all-encompassing persona
which is
really really hard to sort of you know
move into
um not like
who was kind of the man with no face who
just sort of slipped out and you know no
one really kind of worried about filling
his shoes um
this is a very very kind of big
structural problem uh the bottom line
though is uh he's xi jinping is 70 in
2023 um he cannot continue forever he is
mortal alas uh you know we have to tell
the politburo
um
so there's got to be a plan at some
point it just you know when is that plan
going to become apparent
steve can i put you on the spot as well
and give your prediction for what will
characterize the next generation of
chinese leaders
oh i think that's actually very easy
um the next generation leader will be
shaped by xi jinping
the core of the next generation of
leaders if we use generation in the
sense we have been using of
10 years being a political generation
there is no doubt
the next 10 years
whoever comes up
will have to play by the rules set down
by xi jinping
before the 19 party congress in 2017
the politburo standing committee was
essentially
a committee of equals and the general
secretaries was
first among equals by a bit of distance
but essentially still first among equals
since the 19 party congress
xi jinping is now the boss
the rest of the politburo standing
committee members have to write an
annual report to xi jinping
and the dynamics completely changed so
you even if xi jinping should decide
to completely
change the membership of the peripheral
standing committee apart from himself
at the 20th party congress
whoever are being paid to fill those
places
will have to
think what the boss wants
and what the boss will be happy is to
tolerate
and work within those parameters
it matters very little
even if among those six people to be
picked
somebody happens to
have a liberal arts education from a
liberal arts college
whether it's in the united states or the
united kingdom who believes in freedom
and democracy and human rights
that person
will tow the line
as required by the core leader of the
communist party
otherwise that person is on the chopping
board nobody
who is
willing to accept a promotion to the
political standing committee
will remotely take a risk on something
like that
somebody who would would never have been
picked in the first instance
but that is what they said about c as
well isn't it they miscalculated about
xi jinping they thought xi jinping would
be
more
effective as a leader than
uh
jintao i mean there was a sense that the
party was drifting a bit
but there was also
an expectation or a calculation and
misconception
that xi jinping was somebody who would
go along with others
forgetting that
the system itself
allowed
demand in the hot seat to change
the system in place in china
before xi jinping became leader was one
that was meant for a collective
leadership
but it's also a system that
has nothing
ins institutionally to stop
the top boy to become
a strong man leader and that's exactly
what xi jinping did when he became
leader
well on that cheerful note steve tang
and kerry brown thank you so much for
joining chinese whispers
thank you for watching this episode of
chinese whispers if you've just come
across the podcast on youtube you can
find more episodes through searching for
chinese whispers wherever you get your
podcast from there is a brilliant
backlog of episodes not on youtube and
if you have feedback do leave a comment
below preferably constructive and
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel so you never miss any of our
spectator tv shows thanks for watching
[Music]
you